bryce wilson spot start for him he's got
the ball tonight in game one yeah you
see his last five starts uh mixed bag
you see those walks eight walks 15 k's
were good
and strike three came back to get him at
93 miles an hour so a nice comeback good
start one up one down yeah good
fastball's tailing up i think marcostado
is going to be a little bit higher than
it was and it stayed it's playing
one-two pitch swaying enemies chased a
high fastball and buchette goes down on
strikes that's his 41st of the year
two up two down for bryce wilson well he
couldn't ask him to get to a better
start got the fastball at the top of the
zone to get simeon looking and then
climb the ladder on buchet
strike three called he struck out the
side to start the game
now the last time robbie ray faced
atlanta he had a great fastball working
we mentioned he threw 68 fastballs
against the braves and he didn't give up
a run
first pitch swing a base hit by acuna
at 96 miles an hour one way not to
strike out against robbie ray is don't
let him get to two strikes see if he has
the green light 3-0
that one uh might have grazed him on the
way by freeman's aboard
one two fastball down the middle for
strike three called and a big first out
here for robbie ray pitch is golfed into
left field a base here here comes acuna
around third ozzy albee's with a
two-strike hit puts atlanta in front
and ray can't believe he got the barrel
to that ball
he drove it right past biggio and
pachette and the lead-off man comes home
for a first-inning atlanta lead
you finally see ozzie get going from the
right side
to me the pitcher did a chip he laid off
that 95 up
so you see there he gets a slider
3-2
and the fastballs popped up
again very shallow right center field
again the same trio of fielders this
time te oscar hernandez will make the
catch and the braves make ray work very
hard they get one run off them wada
lacuna junior leads off the third he has
singled and scored tonight
and ray brings it swing and a rocket
rope toward left center field that ball
is gone online drive home run for acuna
you talk about hitting a ball under
radar that's exactly what acuna did
there if it didn't go over the wall jeff
it might have gone through the wall
that was an absolute rocket that was the
whole thing you saw ronald running as
hard as he was out of the box chip he
didn't think it was going to be high
enough
fastball a little bit up look how easy
it is to the zone
look at this yeah
that makes a great catch bryce wilson
mixing pitches very well tonight the
reward guys in the fifth no run so far
well he's in the fifth now with biggio
guriel and maguire coming up one pitch
ground ball to second piece of cake for
ozzy albee's biggio out quickly one out
but you want to know how to get another
start up here do this
[Music]
jammed him
dansby's got that
and a low throw dug out by freddy
freeman that was a good play
and rhys mcguire is coming up
and that ball is pulled to first easy
flip to wilson covering and that is a
fast one two three fifth halfway through
in atlanta
to the bottom of the fifth inning the
braves leading the blue jays two to
nothing and christian apache the center
fielder were leaded off for atlanta
struck out in his first at bat
and ponchay on the ground long throw
from biggio skips it off the grass and
guerrero with the stretch
beautiful play at the corners by toronto
biggio had to get rid of it in a big
hurry and poche could not outrun the
baseball the o2
swing and a miss robbie ray made short
work of him strikeout number seven for
the blue jays pitcher
one two on the way swing and a miss he
got him with a slider down
and ray retires acuna bryce wilson's
dealing he just threw seven pitches in
the fifth inning and he is back to work
in the sixth inning and he has the
luxury jeff of starting with the
opposing pitcher robbie ray pitch is
pulled toward the pitcher
and bryce has that ray runs halfway down
the line turns left there's the first
out in the sixth inning
guerrero with a fly ball well head right
field and it's gone
an opposite field two-run homer for
vladimir guerrero jr and just like that
this game is tied
boy here's something else and when he
starts going back in that direction
that's where he got so hotter in the
season center field right center he hit
this one a long way and it was fitting
that went right over acuna's head in
right field the pitch
he did just that
bryce wilson picks up his fifth
strikeout of the game toronto ties it
2-2 bottom six robbie ray's been good
tonight first inning was a little bumpy
gave up a run then acuna hit a solo home
run off him in the third but ray has
only walked one he has struck out eight
he's only allowed two runs back out
there for the bottom of the sixth inning
ray pulled a string last time let's see
what he does here fly ball that's well
hit that's gonna make him comfortable
that ball is gone oh zona on an 02 pitch
takes the selfie and the braves are back
in front
if two out runs are gold two strike hits
have to be platinum and boy did ozuna
need that jeff just his third hit
against the left-handed pitcher all year
and that's definitely not where you want
your o2 pitch
robbie was in a nice little zone there
too
that's going to be one he's going to
want back we go to the eighth inning aj
minter on the pitch for the braves he's
only given up one run in his last nine
appearances
one one swung on hit to right field hit
pretty well
and over the head of a leaping acuna
davis on his way into second base and
the blue jays have the tying run in
scoring position with nobody out here in
the eighth
nope he's swinging and he lines the ball
to left and it's down for a base hit
davis had to wait to see if it would get
out to azuna so he can't score but the
blue jays have the bases loaded with
nobody out for vladimir guerrero jr
first pitch swinging and a base hit into
left field
davis in to score
simeon will stop at third because the
ball was hit so hard but vlady with an
rbi single and the blue jays have tied
it and vladi not wasting any time it's a
first pitch cutter gets the head out and
pulls it sharply into the left field
and jonathan davis just jogging in
1-2 and a weak ground ball to freeman
thought about home nobody's at first and
everybody's safe
and the blue jays take the lead
well i'll tell you what defense is a lot
more than heirs it's about missed plays
and the braves have had two missed
opportunities in this game that have
allowed in this inning that have allowed
the blue jays to score
rio on the way
and it's high ball four to force in
another run 5-3 blue jays well the blue
jays have had some inning here the
two-run lead for the jays and jordan
romano is into the game yeah the bullpen
has been terrific in this ball game
trent thornton tyler chapwood and now
jordan romano four five six here ozzy
albee's austin riley dansby swanson
3-2
slider there for strike three call
well what a good pitch and you could see
the difference in velocity in that slide
it was 87 miles an hour the last thing
ozzy hobbies expected was a breaking
ball
2-2 ground ball to third bishop to
second one and that's all they'll get
the 2-1 fastball
in the air to left field tea oscar
hernandez is there and the blue jays
will hang on to win it